Iker is very much looking forward to
your talk thank you
yeah so this this paper is in a space
that I think David when his introduction
yesterday motivated very well which is
if we're designing mechanisms in an
environment with lots of data we're
gonna have to start thinking about how
to bring it on a metric techniques for
inferring sort of preferences inside the
mechanism design problem this is a joint
work with PhD student Alec Johnson who's
finishing up and on the postdoc market
this year so they're looking for someone
with expertise in that area he's a
fantastic Dennis de capela is in a calm
attrition at University of Virginia and
Ono's uder who is the head of data
science at booking.com we were all
visiting booking.com in amsterdam for
two months in the summer three years ago
where a lot of these questions were
initially posed and we started thinking
about them cool so this papers on
dashboard mechanisms for online
marketplaces so they're they're broadly
two categories of market design I think
are really quite different in terms of
the methods that you're going to be
thinking about to think about them there
are the very infrequent markets like
school choice spectrum auctions where
you look for certain kinds of market
mechanisms and then there are the very
frequent in a million times a day
markets like a Dawkins like uber like
booking.com where you have agents
interacting with these things that are
allocating stuff basically in real time
continuously so this talk is focused on
the latter kind of market okay so online
marketplaces and dashboard mechanisms
what I mean by that is this idea that
the mechanism maybe should be
communicating to the agents something
about what's going on in the marketplace
to help the agents make better decisions
okay that communication is often a
bidding dashboard that the agents have
for seeing you know maybe what happens
counterfactual estimations of what would
happen
four different strategies they might
take in the marketplace and so here is a
in the background of this image as an
example dashboard that was on
booking.com a few years back where it's
a function of the commission that you
might be paying it shows you how much
your visibility on the booking site
might increase
cool so my interest is in generally in
online marketplaces and how to make
online marketplaces function better okay
so what I envision with online
marketplace is the following scenario
there are a bunch of short lived users
and they are matched by the marketplace
with strategic long-lived agents so
again
users might be users on Google and the
agents are advertisers or users might be
people searching for a hotel room on
booking.com and the agents might be the
hotels okay there's some matching
algorithm that prioritizes the agents in
some way and then the users show up and
make a decision about who they're going
to match with okay so they're a bunch of
examples about of these that are quite
relevant I want to make all these things
work better so I don't really think
about any one of them in particular I
want to motivate what I'm thinking about
in the following perspective so
comparing algorithm design and mechanism
design so algorithm design something we
study in computer science a lot in the
last half century given input values
determine a good output and our goal is
to optimize some objective like welfare
mechanism design contrast with this
because we as we allow that the fact
that the input might be strategic and
the agents might manipulate the input to
the MEK has been try to get a better
outcome and so we'd like to determine
outcome that has good welfare and
equally I'd come up with a mechanism has
good outcome in equilibrium when
everyone behaves surgically okay
amazingly there's a very popular
reduction from mechanism design to
algorithm design
it's the VCG mechanism in some scenarios
or more generally there's unbiased
payment mechanisms or implicit payment
mechanisms essentially at a very high
level what these do is they carefully
construct truthful payments to
incentivize everyone to just reveal
their true preferences
okay and here's the problem online
markets don't look like this online
markets do not have truthful payment
formats and you're just not going to be
allowed to design online marketplaces
with these because it gets in the way of
many practical concerns in these markets
or maybe even issues of credibility that
Shane was talking about yesterday okay
so I'm not going to care why we don't
have truthful mechanisms in online
marketplaces I'm just going to assume we
don't have truthful mechanisms in online
marketplaces and see how are we going to
design mechanisms in this world where we
aren't allowed to design truthful
mechanisms okay and one of the issues
with sort of the theory on this is that
this truthful idea is so compelling for
theorists that most of our literature is
stuck there and we haven't spent enough
time thinking about how to do things in
this world okay so this paper and some
other papers I've written recently are
part of what I hope to be a really
fascinating research area that looks at
how to design non truthful mechanisms
cool so here is an example of what I'm
going to be thinking about winner pays
bid format mechanisms these generalize
the first price auction that Sheng was
talking about yesterday the basic idea
is we're gonna ask for bids we're gonna
take the bids and map those to who wins
and then in the end of the day the
winners are gonna pay their bids okay so
in these winner pays bid format
mechanisms there's only one place where
you would as an optimizer get to change
things and that is in step two okay step
two you can decide to map bids to who
wins however you wish okay and the
question is what are good ways of
mapping bids to who wins okay a very
classic way is the highest bid wins
mechanism or for a single item it will
be at the first price auction but you
can imagine this more generally allocate
to the feasible set of agents to
maximize the highest total bid
okay if I was selling one item to two
agents the highest bid wins winner
pasted mechanism is the first price
auction that Shane was talking about I
have a simple example here I'm not going
to talk about it in detail but
essentially if you have bidders with
some values they're gonna strategize and
bid essentially in a full information
environment they're just gonna bid
basically the second highest bid but the
highest bidder bids slightly more and
wins and that's gonna be actually pretty
close to optimal what I want to point
out though is that if you were to change
this environment to make it more complex
so this was selling one exclusive add-on
say any of your favorite search engines
but you can imagine a situation where
you could sell either an exclusive ad or
you could sell a shared ad space where
you show more than one advertiser at
once you choose sell one ad or sell
three ads that could be something you
had and so I could basically take my
same example before these two agents you
want the exclusive ad but I'm going to
add also three agents you want to share
the space okay and in fact the
equilibrium I had before is still an
equilibrium here where these new bidders
just pay zero a bid zero and now we're
getting the same welfare as before of
110 but the optimal welfare was 200
about 300 right in this new equilibrium
and so you see from this example that
not thinking about how to design winner
pays bid mech isms can result in winter
pay speed Beckham's that have really
awful equilibrium off by a factor of
three here obviously you can construct
even worse examples if you want okay so
my question is how do I choose the
algorithm step two so I don't get bad
outcomes like this in equilibrium
cool so there are actually two
challenges that I think are the big
challenges for winner pays bid or non
truthful mechanisms one challenge is
that the agent strategies themselves are
non-trivial if I was told to you bidding
in a scenario come up with a bid you'd
be like I don't know how to do that okay
the other challenge is it's that
equilibrium can be very bad so I'm gonna
be proposing solutions today they're
gonna address both of these challenges
okay my solution is bidding dashboards
okay I'm gonna publish a dashboard which
attempts to give the agents
counterfactual information about what
would happen for every bid they might
put in the auction that makes bidding
easy you just optimize for the dashboard
okay I'm then going to think okay if
we're designing dashboards maybe that
might change how we think about
designing the mechanism because we have
given them a dashboard and if they're
responding to it
well that might help us in some way so
I'm going to then be thinking about how
should I be designing this market
mechanism that is aware of the fact that
I'm giving the agents a dashboard and
they're responding to it
okay the main questions I want to
address here what dashboard do I want
what mechanism do I want I'm imagining I
have these long-lived agents that are
bidding every second in these in this
market mechanism maybe things are
evolving over time but that'll be a
detail I'll talk about in the future
again so think about the setting of
hotels or advertisers matching to user
so at a given time there's one user
shows up who do I match the user to the
agents are the hotels and the users
matching to the hotel rooms with some
preferences of the user the hotels are
not identical but the agents are the
hotel's the user is being allocated to
the hotel in some way okay into all the
hotel as the user today is a different
user from tomorrow maybe and some user
might be a business user or whatever but
it's it's not going to be important for
the discussion cool so I'm gonna answer
the second question first I'm going to
tell you exactly the dashboard mechanism
might have in mind it's very similar to
ideas that were mentioned in some of the
past talk sangwoo's talk for example but
I'm gonna do what he said not to do sort
of so I'm gonna publish a dashboard
which is my estimate of how we're gonna
map bids to the likelihood of winning
I'm then going to ask for bids and then
I'm gonna assume that the bidders have
actually responded to the dashboard I
published okay if they've actually
responded to the dashboard I published
that I can really easily invert their
action to get their preference okay
so I invert their infer the values from
the bids as best response to the
dashboard and now I'm in a great
position because I know what their
values are and I would like to have my
market be the most efficient possible
okay I'm not trying to maximize revenue
I want an efficient market
place and so I'm just gonna run this
desired allocation role which my
engineers have given me which is
optimizing the total welfare on my
platform okay with the true values not
the bids okay and of course I'm required
to use a winner pays bid mechanism so
the winners pay their bids okay
so here's a main question I think I
might answer your question but let me
get let's take a second so the main
question is this seems wrong and maybe
I'm gonna get sued so I'm gonna change
it a little bit and say well okay in the
first step I was publishing a dashboard
maybe my choice of dashboard if impact
on whether this is a good approach or
not and so I'm gonna ask the question
differently and say well what for what
dashboards is this mechanism a good
mechanism it seems wrong cuz I told them
there was this dashboard and then I went
and did something that had nothing to do
with the dashboard I got their values
and I implemented the efficient outcome
yeah but so I published what I'm gonna
do you make a choice and then you get
something that may be different from
what you thought your choice was giving
you that's why it seems wrong well I
have a chicken-and-egg problem right
because you know I mean think about the
first day so it's fairly easy to get an
equilibrium for result but then you're
worried about maybe getting to the
equilibrium but exactly so the and
things could be changing over time in
which case maybe it's never right
question still
what exactly so this is the main point
of the entire talk so we're gonna be
addressing what is binding about the
dashboard yeah
okay so to give you some overview I'm
gonna tell you how to construct
dashboard so I'm gonna give you several
designs of dashboards I'm gonna give you
dashboards with increasing good
properties okay
for the first result it's going to be
David parks as result it's going to be
in static environment if the static
values but following the dashboard
converges to an equilibrium okay and
then I'm gonna give you a more
sophisticated dashboard that has a
stronger property in dynamic
environments but if you have a static
value you want to follow the dashboard
so even if things are changing
underneath you you still want to follow
the dashboard okay
following the dashboard alchemy
converges to what would have happened
for you if we had run the sequential
truthful mechanism instead a dashboard
is a counterfactual estimation of what
might happen for you for various bids
you could place but I'm gonna formally
define it on the next slide so if you
want a mathematical definition it's
coming okay and then my strongest result
is in dynamic environments with dynamic
values the dashboard mechanism is going
to be approximately strategically
equivalent to running the sequential
truthful mechanism with the same
allocation algorithm that the engineers
gave me
okay so my engineers give me an
allocation algorithm I'm going to assume
it's monotone meaning the higher value
and a provider has the higher
probability the agent will get served
and we all know that there's truthful
payments that go along with this
allocation rule and so the outcome of my
dashboards the - was going to be
basically strategically equivalent to
the truthful mechanism and following the
dashboard meaning bidding your best
response for your value in the dashboard
is going to be corresponding to the
truth telling strategy and the
sequential truthful mechanism yes
designer as an agent know exactly what
you do for any sort of bits that are
made after the dashboard and what how
you allocate based on that you're asking
about commitment the usual you commit to
what you do with all the bits that are
made after the dashboard yes here's my
my philosophy on commitment I'm in a
repeated environment okay and if if
we're interacting and I keep saying the
wrong thing and you keep not getting
good payoff you're just gonna leave
that's the way I should think of the
mechanism as sort of that's what agents
just know is gonna happen before any big
profile they know what to make isn't
it's actually it's not important it's
not gonna be important that's actually
strong result so this sequential
truthful mechanism has ex-post Nash
afoul of being truthful right sequential
truthful mechanism and so you don't have
to actually know what's gonna happen in
the sequential truthful mechons mean
either well you have to know in my
dashboard mechanism
so the environment could be changing
under you you might not know it
okay so here is my outline I've given
you some motivation I'm going to spend
some time talking about single agent
mechanisms which are way easier than
multiple agent mechanisms for designing
winner pays bid mechanisms for I'm then
gonna give you my dashboard
constructions in some of the analyses
we'll see how much time I have and the
last thing which I am gonna guess I'm
not going to have time for is and I'll
work then refer you to the paper is what
I call single call dashboard mechanisms
and this is the following difference
which is actually really important
practically in theory land is not so
important here's the the point so in
many online marketplaces I only know
what my engineered algum is gonna do by
actually running it for live right
that's the only way I know what would
have what my algorithm does okay and in
particular I don't know what the
probability is in advertiser would have
gotten a click or the probably a hotel
would have gotten the booking if they
had put in a different bid because I
didn't have that bit I didn't try that
there's no way to do that without
actually running it live so the single
call model is the model where I can only
ever run my have access to my algorithm
by running it okay and so the point is
is that all the dashboards I'm going to
construct are going to be able to be
also constructed in the single call
model which is I think the practical
implementation of this
so it's these bidding dashboards that
are in place in many of these mechanisms
it's a it's for the it's like a console
where the outer headers come and they
see all the parameters they have to
configure and they also potentially get
some feedback about what might happen
when they change their bid or other
parameters of their campaign no they do
not get to see lots of people's bids
they see predictions of what might
happen for various bids of that fairs
okay cool so I want to jump into the
first topic which is understanding
single agent mechanisms okay so I have a
single agent with value V a truthful
mechanism is going to be defined by an
allocation rule X and a payment rule P
where X maps v2 the probability of
winning and P maps v2 the expected
payment made by the agent okay a winner
pays bid mechanism I'm gonna put Tilda's
on these to denote that it has a bit
allocation rule which maps bids not
values to allocation probabilities and
bids not values to payments for winter
pace bid that's easy because the payment
with a given bid is just your bid times
you're probably a winning okay so if a
winner pays bid meccans I've already
told you what the payment rule is okay
I'll do know B if the strategy of
calligraphic blue b as a strategy which
maps values to bids and then the
revelation principle is pretty nice it
tells me that if I understand truthful
mechanism I also understand winner pays
bid mechanisms because this X tilde B
tilde P tail that can only be a non
truthful mechanism in equilibrium with
bids B if when I compose it with my
allocation rule I get a truthful
mechanism that satisfy a truthful
mechanism okay and so now I can use the
characterization of truthful equilibria
to understand what's possible in this
space so a mechanism is truthful if and
only if this X is monotonically
non-decreasing
and the payment rule satisfies this
payment identity of Roger Myerson
okay this payment identity probably is
not new for almost everybody here but
just to see a pictorial representation
of it if my allocation rules is black
increasing non decreasing line okay
then B times X is the surplus which is
this red rectangle v times a public of
winning this minus this term here that's
the area underneath the curve right I
integrate I get the underneath the curve
okay that turns out to be the utility
the agent gets because the payments are
equal to the surplus minus this utility
that's what the designer gets in terms
of payments the area above the curve
okay so that's the picture you should
have in your mind about this care
Christian and basically what I'm saying
is if I tell you my probably of winning
I'm also telling you the payment up to a
p0 term which is how much player with
value zero pays so you can imagine the
dashboard being this curb X but if we're
designing a winner pays bid mechanism we
ought to give the dashboard in bid space
not value space so we'll give it
translate into bid space and so I'm
about to do that
okay so cool this is if I want to design
a truthful mechanism what if someone
gave me my engineers give me X and they
said I want you to do this in value
space but you need to do this with a
winner pays bid rule okay so you need to
ask for bids map the bids to a
probability of winning and then if the
person wins they pay their bid okay so
that's actually also quite easy so
basically you can use the revenue
equivalents idea to salt to do this and
I'm basically going to do that right now
so cool our payment had to be this for
the truthful mechanism but we know our
payment in the winter pace bid mechanism
is bid times probably of winning okay so
the expected payment divided by my
probably wouldn't have to be equal to my
bid so I can solve for it with this
formula so if you tell me you want to
implement this X I can tell you well
your strategy in the winter pasted
mechanism that implements that X has to
be this bid function and now as long as
this bid function is invertible right
it's monotonic then I can just invert it
and put it into X and so X tilde be my
winner pays bid rule is just take my bid
invert it with the bid function I know
has to be the only bid function that
works here right and plug that into X
the engineer's allocation algorithm and
I get the thing I want
okay interestingly and I did not realize
this for a long time so when I'm
implementing truthful mechanisms I can
have any p0 I want for non truthful
mechanisms actually p0 can be at most
zero and the reason why is that this is
not my own if I have positive p0 and
that's because look at p0 over XIV as
this goes to 0 when you get small this
thing goes to infinity and the guide
with value going to 0 has to be bidding
going to infinity which obviously can't
happen in the mechanism right so
actually meyerson's characterization can
be refined for winner pays bid
mechanisms to require p0 to be
non-positive
that'll be important later remember that
yes question no there was no
distribution here I have only one player
and my engineers had given me the
allocation rule and I know the
allocation rule for one player and
usually in mechanisms I'm that
allocation rule comes from the
distribution of other players but from
my one player example I'm just assuming
have a fixed allocation rule good
you have to invert the be like I'm
imagining my engineers for some reason
didn't want to serve an agent with low
value so they gave me a one agent
mechanism with a probabilistic
allocation rule that's a strange thing
this is gonna plug into my later
analysis where it'll come from other
bidders but for now we don't have to
even think about other bidders I'm
worried about how do you invert the
function like I don't see how to invert
this crazy integral thing are you just
gonna mean it's a monotonic function I
mean do it numerically
so this is just like if you took a
second price auction use of the cup
plate the equilibrium Vincent a first
price exactly if you were solving for
the bid strategy in the first price
auction from a second price auction you
can have no equivalence you've done
exactly this
the source of the assumption is that
computers are optimizing so there are
they're actually playing yeah I have one
bidder at one bidder this matter has a
value I want the values to mapped
allocation probabilities by the rule my
engineers get gave me okay but I'm
required to charge winners their bids so
I have to come up with a new bid
allocation rule and this is exactly just
how you do it but the assumption is that
you're that Peter is optimizing
correctly yes yes so the point is this
is the right optimal strategy for the
bidder when I correct me to derive the
mechanism X tilde
okay so this was the one bitter case
it's all super easy things get very
difficult very quickly when I consider
more bitters because I have X given in
value space and if values are now a
profile that I need to simultaneously
solve for all the values so that when
one player manipulates their value I get
the right curve and I get the right bid
and everything is going to sort of break
in doing this directly for multiple
bidders so the big essentially the if
you want to like from a theoretical
point of view you can view the the work
that we did in this paper is reducing
the multi bidder case to the single
bitter analysis
I am going to be designing mechanisms
for Nash implementation not BAE's Nash
and so there's full information on the
part of the the bidders and so interim
is not a thing in what I'm doing okay
dashboard construction and analysis I'm
going to go over some of the main ideas
and then we'll go into some more detail
okay I guess there's a high level of
what are the ideas that go into coming
up with a good dashboard okay so here's
a good first idea use historical values
as the values you're gonna plug into the
allocation rule to estimate the
dashboard that's a pretty good idea if
values are constant that's going to be
pretty reasonable okay then I can as I
said before and for agents values from
the best fonts the dashboard and I can
use these past inferred values in future
estimated dashboards okay I'm gonna get
from these first two bullets follow -
what's gonna converge to - as David
suggested another really helpful idea
and we'll see why is actually I should
only update my dashboard when the agent
wins
okay well CY that's a really good idea
I'm gonna give a very formal definition
on the next slide this right intuition
for the main ideas that go into things
but I'll have a formal definition do you
think waiting is going to be fine okay
so if I only up the debt LPG dashboard
when an agent is allocated then the paid
payments I'm gonna sign are going to
converge to the truthful payments for
static that are for a static value agent
okay so even if the environment is
changing dynamically the payments will
converge okay so much stronger than the
natural
okay and then the last idea if I want
things to work with dynamic values and
dynamic agents the idea is look my
dashboard might be wrong I don't know
what the future holds so match what
might be wrong let's keep track of how
much it's wrong because we do know
ex-post
how much it's wrong okay and then I'm
just going to keep track of how much I
charge people incorrectly and give them
a rebate in the future and I can give
them that rebate by adding that to the
dashboard I can add it essentially as
adding it to the p0 term right except
that I can't really as I showed you I
can only have negative non positive p0
and so I have to sort of do that a
little bit more cleverly
okay and this last thing bullet for this
is a really popular idea in designing
mechanism for repeated environments
okay this idea of linking decisions
across rounds makes things a lot easier
so I'm going to link decisions across
rounds I'm going to keep track of how
much my payments were wrong and I'm
going to guarantee I'm going to give
that person that payment back okay
and this is gonna give me approximate so
he took equivalents to the sequential
truthful mechanism cool you guys have
been demanding definitions so here's my
dynamic model I have stages 1 through T
I'll have valuation profiles that could
be different in every stage so V sub I
super s is player i's value in stage s
okay I have a surpassed ik allocation
algorithm which is going to map this is
from the engineers the profile of values
to probabilities of winning okay inside
this is the user's choice which is why
it's probably stochastic so the user
comes and they maybe we model them
randomly so random agents gonna win okay
the reason why this might change for the
round is because different users in
different rounds and so they might make
different choices
okay we have linear utilities I'm
requiring winner pays bid in each round
and I'm gonna occasionally consider the
static model where I'm gonna drop the
super s's superscript on s because
everything's gonna be the same
okay values be the same in every round
and the stage allocation will be the
same in every round yeah follow the
value profile
I'm sorry what was the question yeah so
this is the allocation algorithm in
value space that my engineers want so
I'm assuming my engineers found a good
way to map values to who should win to
optimize the platform and my job is to
design the bid allocation rule in bid
space that has good properties with
winner pays bid payment semantics yeah
so again if I don't have a tilde it
means it's in value space if I do have a
tilde it's in bid space
okay so I would love to design this
winter pace mechanism to single call
implement the sequential choice
this basically secret to the series of
central twice rules
cool now to formally define our
dashboard so our dashboard is going to
map it's going to basically be counter
estimates of what would happen for any
bid of the agent what are they likely to
get served this is a profile of bid
allocation rules with one bid allocation
rule for each agent okay an agent oh I
get to see their bid allocation rule I'm
gonna be talking about the algorithm
that we're actually running and the
dashboard were showing so it's kind of
helpful to have different notation for
those two so the algorithm is going to
be allocations payments bid allocation
rules and bid strategy for the dashboard
it'll be allocations payments a bit
allocation rule bid strategy
okay we're always going to be running
this but we're going to be showing them
this
okay so here's my dashboard mechanism
formerly I wanted to find the bit
allocation rule to map bids to who wins
I'm given some dashboard and I'm given
the stage allocation algorithm
okay later I'm gonna be telling you how
to construct the dashboard that I want
to be given in this brown so the good
things happen but for now I'm given the
dashboard so I'm gonna publish my
dashboard and solicit bids I'm then
going to infer values using the
inversion of the bid function for the
dashboard okay and I'm then gonna just
run my stage allocation album if the
engineers gave me on the inferred values
and of course charge people their bids
so if you win you pay your bid it's
gonna be readily apparent when they did
something and they get something else
but sure I'm gonna prove a result that
says that by my dashboard is
approximately Street equivalent to
bidding truthfully in a truthful
mechanism okay that's my end result so
and that's a ex-post Nash in a
sequential truthful mechanism so it
doesn't matter what the agent knows but
it does matter that they believe that
things are sort of lined up right so
it's a great question to talk about
maybe offline
okay so um this is my mechanism you see
what dashboards are I'm now gonna give
you I told you I'm gonna progressively
make my dashboards more and more
complicated
so my first simplest dashboard is just
the last stage inferred values dashboard
so in stage s what I'm gonna do is look
at the inferred values I had from the
last stage and then gonna say well what
if I plug these inferred values into the
last stages allocation rule but I change
the player i's value in that to get an
allocation rule which I'll call Y and
then I convert that into bid space by
the single agent construction for every
player to get a bit allocation rule
which is my dashboard
so I just look at what we were doing
last stage and I give them the bit
allocation with the corresponds to that
so here's the static analysis which
David predicted following the dashboard
converges to a Nash equilibrium and in
fact in to state two rounds right if we
both all fall the dashboard two stages
in a row then in the second round the
dashboards right and it was best
response to do what the dashboard says
oh that's the least interesting result
here however I like it because it says
that in steady state there's nothing to
do okay so now the problem is is dealing
with changes in the environment maybe
the allocation rules changing or bitter
show up and leave that's going to be so
it might have to do some additional work
to get things to be good then but in
steady-state we essentially do nothing
so just for reference if we were to run
a sequential truthful mechanism there
all kinds of other equilibrium then
playing truthfully in a sequential
truthful mechanism yeah also advise
people to father dashboard so I really
care about the sequential properties not
the single round properties of Nash and
so I'm gonna be stuck with all of the
funny equilibrium that the central truth
of my cousin has I can't get rid of them
cool so that's my static analysis I now
want to generalize come up with a better
dashboard for settings where the
environment could be changing but a
player has the same persistent value in
every round okay so this is just the
last winning stage dashboard and here's
what I do for every agent the dashboard
I offered them is coming from the
allocation rule that they received the
last time they won
the theorem is is that following a
dashboard with a static value converges
to the right average outcome in the
sequential truthfull mechanism if we are
running a sequential truthful mechanism
for this agent
okay the proof is simple and cute okay
so fix the value B that you might have
consider a successive winning sadist I'm
gonna index my stages that I won by K so
SK minus one was the last time I run and
SK is this time I run I won the auction
and here's the thing the big you give me
an SK is responding for this value to
the dashboard from SK minus one which is
the correct dashboard fresh K minus one
so the amount you make now when you win
is the right amount to have paid me in
the last round that you won okay in
other words the bid strategy in this
round is equal to the correct bid
strategy for the last round cool if I
sum the total payments over all rounds
this imbalance across I just paid you at
the wrong time I paid you the right
amount but the wrong time okay and
everything cancels except for the first
and last round and the first and last
round difference of bids is at most V
okay because the bids difference of any
two bids in a mechanism where value V
can be at most different to V
so even though my dashboard has you pay
the wrong amount at the time you win the
next time you pay me the right amount so
it's almost like a deferred payment
mechanism essentially you pay me the
right amount next time okay we're
playing in a repeated game so I don't
care if you pay me the right amount this
time or next time you're gonna pay me
the right amount eventually and so why
worry about it
this requires my value to be the same in
every round otherwise the payment might
not be the right amount next time Phi
value changed okay so the last thing I'm
going to do is try to come up with a
dashboard that works okay when my values
changing and I already gave you the idea
for this but basically the intuition is
is well if my allocation rule is
changing across rounds then my payments
might be incorrect when I publish the
wrong dashboard let's keep track of how
incorrect my payments are from the wrong
dashboard add that to a balance and
let's make sure that I collect that
balance eventually in the future
okay this is actually not very
complicated there are some like pretty
subtle things you do want to do to get
it right in particular if I'm collecting
balance in the future I want to really
make sure I don't overshoot and so if I
have if I owed you a dollar it'd be
horrible with next round we overshot and
now you owe me ten dollars right that'd
be and then that could like oscillate
out of control and just result with
really high in balance of payments so we
have an inferred value if he had we
implemented allocation X we have an
actual bid see we had a desired bid B
and we really wish C was equal to B that
had been the right payments for this
round if C was B when I charg you B when
you win all right but we didn't get that
and so there's a payment residual which
is the difference in these two that's
sort of how much wrong we had how much
the payments were wrong
okay so I'm just gonna every round add
the payment residual to a balance adjust
the dashboard payments by putting this
into the p0 term the payment you play
with value 0 that doesn't quite work as
I said but we can approximate that and
you can see the paper for the details on
how to approximate that
okay cool so the details and I think I
want to skip given the time because it's
not all that exciting the main lemmas
that go into analyzing this dashboard
are proving that the additional payment
residual from every round is bounded
between minus V and V that we resolved a
balance but we never overshoots the
amount we resolve is between l2 and some
a to less than one and the total balance
and that unresolved payment residual
from round K after K winning stages sort
of exponentially or decreases
I wanna as I predicted I don't have time
to talk about the single call mechanisms
so see the paper for that and my
discussion is fairly straightforward
online markets can have bad equilibria
the sequential - what backsons can
implement any outcome of any sequential
truthful mechanism a nice thing is that
we have to do sort of complicated
rebalancing to fix things only when
there's changes in the environment
okay that sort of dashboard naturally
rebalance themself otherwise some
directions I think there are interesting
approaches for making this practical one
thing I especially think are interesting
is that if you can make your dashboard
estimates better that's gonna make a
better user in user experience but the
theory that we did is going to work even
if the dashboards wrong so get a
theoretical method for resolving balance
that's going to work for any - where you
come up with and you can use any
heuristics you want to show a dashboard
and this rebalancing approach
automatically corrects for mistakes that
you made and gives you the good
incentives I think this area of
designing a theory for non truthful
mechanisms is incredibly important it's
been overlooked in the literature for
almost the entirety of the literature on
mechanism design and I think we need to
think about it especially with these
applications still online markets and I
think there's a technical thing that is
quite interesting which is designing
mechanisms based on bid inversion which
we haven't seen very much it but I think
it's a really powerful idea that when we
put bid inversion into mechanism design
we can actually do some things we
weren't able to do before
oh thank you very much do bidders trust
the dashboard wasn't there paper you
know there's no about doing a having a
sort of recommendation to roll yeah a
lot of you know yeah yeah so I think I
think Trust is a super important issue
and I think that the fact that the thing
we say is actually I mean the payments
are gonna be if you have a static value
your payments are right the next time
for the last time as I showed you but
maybe that's not good enough for the
experience of the agents and the
mechanism there like that was way off
from what you said was gonna happen and
I don't believe what's going on at all
and now I'm sort of very reluctant to
follow any strategy yeah I think that's
a big issue and so I would lump that
into sort of practical approaches for
dashboards and I think that resolving
that making the user experience better
is a key practical issue
just to follow up on that question the
so they don't actually have to follow
what's in the dashboard or do they
actually have to optimize the taking the
dashboard and at face value like it
there's a compliance problem so maybe
they don't completely think of it so it
does influence their behavior yeah so
here's the thing in every round I assume
their value is in best response to the
dashboard and we produced the efficient
outcome and in the long run so the the
theorem that I did in the state but I
said many times equivalents to the
sequential truthful mechanism we're
fondly dashboard corresponds to bidding
truthfully what does that mean if you
don't follow dashboard some round you've
been some other buddy it's like in the
long run you were bidding in a truthful
mekansm you bid the wrong value which
means you lost okay so that's correct
and I think in this in what I propose
here I think there's an definitely an
opportunity of them not to learn and one
of the reasons why is that the payment
is delayed and it's hard to realize that
oh these things are balancing as I
attribute the payment here to this I
mean so that it's confusing and so
that's why I say I think they're
practical challenges and getting there
and sort of how you explain this and how
you but payment you're charged the
payment at the moment of allocation and
these high-frequency auctions you can
give up
monthly bill and then the monthly bill
will be approximately correct yeah and
so potentially aggregating across many
payments would make it seem much more
accurate because it is it's like only
the first and last one or wrong and then
if you aggregate over the month as
Nicole says then then it would be pretty
close to right on yeah see given those
you're gonna win
sarcastically going forward I think it
would change because I'm talking you the
wrong amount now and talking the right
amount later and so I'm talking more now
or less later I think it would change no
cuz I don't think that the rates people
discount are our higher frequency than
the amount they're allocated so long as
your next time I mean as long as you're
patient enough for your next allocation
and it's I don't think it makes a
difference for real applications so if I
had a static pay as big mechanism I
wanted to implement and principle I
could teach people using a dashboard to
play the ex post Nash equilibrium by
breaking it up into a sequence right
could be seen as like a learning tool
for static settings yes you could take
your item and allocate into fractional
items and actually alkie each one and
you should maybe get to what you want
very quickly
I haven't thought about that very
carefully
great thank you
[Applause]